al al al
e al al
k
ah
an al al al al al
al
Ok let's Uh Let's go ahead and get
started
um today is um um One of the many
Masters thesis Def sessions that that we
do and um We have One of Our Uh  Master
students Who is defending Uh Dr
Charlie Otero from hospital Italiana in
Buenos Aires and Uh Charlie like um a
number of Our uh trainees uh has been
funded by Our Grant from the nih fogy
International Center Uh That's a
collaboration with um hospital Italiana
in in Buenos Aires  Aires and um Uh If he
succeeds today he'll be the fourth um
fourth yeah fourth person to um Uh
complete the Masters program um like
many He's a physician um Who was
previously um Uh working at
Italian hospital um did the Medical informatics
residency there and
Under the Uh local Uh mentorship of Uh
Dr Paul Otero relation um and um fern
deos the um Head of the Uh informatics
program there so um I will turn it over
to
char Thank you very much for
coming I want to believe that you are
here for  my presentation and Not For the
I want to share my My study with you
about improving granularity in the
electronic Health record Problem but
First of all Let me introducing the con
of oriented Health record It was It was
a documentation model created by
Lawrence in by the  end of the 60 and is
a New concept in Medical record that
represents the clinical work Flow and
organized the Data for other issues More
Than the clinical care
H billing research and all
administrative process this model
associate clinical not with the Health
Problem and also facilitate the
association with a Problem and a
therapeutic plan this mod this model was
created for a model paper model
documentation but this structure
facilitate the
informatization issues so what is a
Problem list there are a lot of
definition that What is a Problem Every
association related with Health
informatic  have One definition I mix all
Together there And I want to share
with you this definition that Say that
the list of the list of Problem is a le
of all patients diagnosis single
symptoms and explain findings abnormal
physical findings and psychosocial and
cultural issues and they  Also Take Note
of the problem list is not static is a
dynamic list of What happens with the
patient as much with update at should
have an appropriate Level of
detail for Us hital Italiano de Buenos
Aires the problem is Any condition that
generates a contact between the  patient
and The People in the health Team but
also Any conduct Any action Take by the
healthcare Team related with this
specific
patient so Why use a Problem l Why use a
Problem oriented electronic Health
record this model facilitates the
longitudinal
care improve the Quality of care if  you
see some of the several reports That you
can find in the literature you can
See That this model Of documentation Not
only improve the Quality but also the
communication into Provider and
also Is A Good model for development and
implementation for the clinical decision
Support  System facilitate research and
implementation of healthcare program and
also is useful for management and
administrative task if you take a point
of more technical issues this model
facilitates the storage and organization
of the information in the badas and also
allows developers to create more Easy
visualization for the  clinical
Data so If We know that the problem list
is a really good option for clinical
documentation Why physicians don't use
the problem l or at least don't use in
the way that We are thinking they
should use First they I will comment
with you this article with from white
and and his Team they Say that One of
the topic Because physicians don't use
the problem is Because this System Don't
respect the real workflow of the
clinician and also there are a big lack
in the policies  about Who is the owner
on the the problem of the problem list
and Who has the responsibility to Take
care of the Quality of this Problem list
but so physician says that Data in
Problem list is not relevant and they
find other alternative to find more
accurate and  Quality Data When using
electronic Health record
Problem another consideration from
Because doctors don't use the list is
about They don't really know how to use
the problem list and Which are the
uses for
this for this list and also they Say
that They  don't receive Support and
education and How to use and How to
maintain the in some countries like
Argentina the problem oriented
electronic Health record is
not a model that you Us to learn
in the Medical School so there are also
some culture considerations that  Maybe
you can a hospital using a Problem
list for documentation And You Never
seen this model in the School of
medicine and also some problem and Easy to to
use Because they have not good
presentation or good visualization but
One of the main considerations Because
Because physicians to use the problem
list is about the completeness and
accuracy of the problem list only for
Take an idea What is the completeness of
the problem list another paper of right
find that you can find omissions in the
problem list that Go from the 5%  We are
Talking About Kid disease from Almost
80% if you are looking for information
about breast Cancer and the granularity
the Level of detail that collaborates
with a good accuracy of the problem list
is the the Level of detail that this
Problem list has in this sense  ahima
American Health information of
management association says that details
the appropriate content of the problem
list and Defines diagnosis When problems
become more specific must be a
responsibility of the physicians
using the problem list and give an
example for example chronic coke could
be updated to  chronic disease pulmonary
um chronic obstr pulmonary disease When
A diagnosis is
made so in this context granularity is
one of the main features to improve the
accuracy of the problem list and several
organizations like ag Level 7 sh
commission for hospital accreditations
aima and some National National  program
here in the United State like meaningful
use recommend that the list must be
updated and must contain the appropriate
Level of detail but is this
Level of
detail important for all The People in
the health Team we can think this
consideration about patient versus
population  if you in a particular and
specific patient Maybe you need the more
detailed information your as a physician
need to make decision for a specific
patient and more detail could be more
beneficial for this patient If you're
thinking Maybe in population and you are
taking public  Health decisions Maybe
more aggregate Data could be more useful
if you are thinking to make some
decisions One of the biggest
consideration is that if you have
detailed information you can go to an
aggregate information but if you decide
to only Store aggregate information you
Lost the chance  to go back and obtain
detail information so It's important to
take an idea What is the use of this
information and to take advantage of for
example terminology service to go from
detail information to aggregate
information but Always tak in account
that if you don't  Store the information
in the appropriate
detail you can obtain this detail then
so in summary Maybe more useful for
patients and physicians consideration to
have a more detailed Problem list than
the public
Health
considerations but Why and at
Italian hospital are we so worry about the
Quality  of the problem l Because We have
Our own electronic Health record that is
Problem oriented electronic Health
record and Every process in Our hospital
is related to a Health Problem Every
clinical Note Every drug prescription
Every complementary study must be
associated with the problem Health and
also this  Problem list are Used For
other process into the institution like
administrative task research process
clinical decision Support development
and health
programs only to give you an idea How
important is for Us a Problem We have
in Our System about 9 Million problems
created In The History of  Our electronic
Health record only The Last year 1.2
Million of Problem were created and the
mean of the problem in Our System is six
problems if you
take a look Where physicians create
these problems the ambulatory setting
the patient settings create More Than
the Half that these problems  in Our
System so for us an accurate Problem
list with an adequate Level of detail
allow Us to optimize the clinical care
the research process and the
administrative task and improve by the
end the Quality of care of Our
patients the objective So The objective
of my project  was to measure the Level
of detail in the problem list testing
clinical Case in two different interfaces
and for
that the design of the study was test
the granularity the Level of detail
using clinical vi clinical Case that
guide the user to Select a
Problem the study was  perform
Italian hospital of Buenos Aires in Argentina is
Real an academic Center but this real
not hospital is a Network with two
hospital More Than
20 ambulatory Clinic 750 beds and 2.8
Million patient visit per year We have
about 50,000 discharge in a year and
also We have  a Health
Insurance and we are in charge of
150,000
patients This is Our electronic Health
record Problem
list and in Our electronic Health record
Problem list the physician input in
freeex the Health Problem that he or She
want to input in the problem list We
have  a terminology server that analyzes
this term and evaluate If that term is
valid Or Not valid This term is not
valid for example physician right
prescription that is not really Health
Problem the System Ask for a New Problem
but If the term is valid the terminology
server offer  the best match Which the
term That the physician input but also
Give some options that the
physicians can put Choice to elevate the
Level of detail of the problem then the
physicians Choice go to the to the
problem
list this study was performed with 20
physicians that  they were randomly
Select inclusion criteria was physicians
that could be a staff or trainees with a
minimum of six months of use of Our
electronic Health record and we excluded
physicians working in Our department or
related to the development of the
study and this study was approved by  the
irb at Italian hospital and here and in
ohsu three clinical Case We are Select
One related to osteomelitis One related
to pneumonia and The Last with shoulder
Pain each clinical Case was reviewed in
detail for a for a Team of physicians
and the maximum Level of detail  for this
Case Was identified and for the the
analysis and the text of each Case was
given in printed car to each subs
participating in the
study for the study as I Tell you before
two documentation strategies were Us one
is Our current evas electronic Health
record Which  provides the actual
interface Problem entry into the problem
list and a New prototype interface with
New options available for use
you can see here Again Our electronic he
record Problem list and This is the
window that physicians use When Are
trying to input the problem list you  can
see in the number one the Field to
write the the problem and Search the
preferred term in number two the options in
number three and you can see also View
The Last selection in number four and
the continuous Button in Number Five the
new prototype interface  is quite similar
The Only things that are different that
there are a different organization of
the Data you have the option to Search
the prefer term in number two option in
number three But You also have another
consideration for the options in this
Case physician is looking for  pneumonia
and you have a Number Five pneumonia
classification for the argentinian
pneumologist association but also It's
important to Note that in this interface
you have in number six other option or
attributes that you can add to the
problem when you are creating the
problem list trying to get  more specific
and trying to get more detail to
the problem list then you can see number
Seven How the term is Will be created
and then you have also a definition of
the problem you can say that this that
is Used by doctors so they should
know the definition of the problem that
they were creating but believe me that
When we are trying to input more
specific information for example the
stage of the hypertension Maybe They
don't know what is the Level to change
One stage to another stage so we decide  to
put some information in the definition to
give them some facility to decide
If hypertension Level One hypertension
Level two and then you have in the
number n Number Nine Sorry a Button to
continue the process
for this study granularity was defined
based on sensitivity of  documentation
compared with was theine for each Case
Uh presented to the to the sub I'm sorry
and sensitivity Was the Level of detail
identify for this subset in this Case
divided by the total number of detail
decare for for this clinical clinical
Case This is an  idea How physicians see
the clinical Case they were exposed
with three clinical Case and were asked to
document pertinent Problem using each of
two strategies and this result in six
Case strategy per
subject Data was working paper Translate
to english and
analyze and these Are The Three  cases
this one is about osteomelitis
a 41y old male patient with hypertension
and diabetes that is hospitalized for
ral canal osteomelitis refractory to
therapy with pacin in basan you can see
here Five Level of
details the Second Case is about a
patient with pneumonia is a patient that
is was admitted to the hospital with
diagnosis of acute Community pneumonia
based on the right lung and this Case
also has five levels of
detail and This is the number three Case
It's a 35 years old that Come to the
Clinic with
an acute staving type  Pain in right
shoulder and this Case also have F Level
Of detail You can see here for example
Pain is a clinical finding acute that is
a cse stavin that is other attributes in
this case type of Pain shoulder that
is the finding Side and right that  is
the
laterality 20 tests were performed in
April 2014 20 physicians participated in
this study and Give Me Almost an hour
of their Time for me to participate in
the study and believe me that it's not
Easy
to
obtain Almost an Hour of each physician
for  play with the with the System the
minage for participants was 39 years old
55 were G specialty internal medicine 45
per and family physician 55 per and the
role was 60 staff and 40%
trainees This is their these are the the
results for the First clinical case  of
elitis There is the the analysis of
information each Line is a participant
in the study and each column is a
Level of detail and you have two Big
groups One For interface One and One For
interface two in this Case sensitivity in
general was 56 with a  Ram for 40 to
60 and if you Take account each
interface separately 53 for interface
One and 5% for interface 2 and no
statistical difference was found but if
you Take account specific of the Level
Of detail You can find that the
clinical finding  and the finding Side
was selected in in All the cases All the
participant Select this kind of
information but if you Take account of
the laterality you can See That in
interface 2 about 95 Select the
laterality as an important consideration
When They are creating a Problem but
only 65 per in interface One Select that
the laterality of the disease was
important for document but here
There is an interesting consideration
that nobody believes that the condition
That the refractory to to therapy and
the antibiotic use in this
patient but  so the
refractory nobody chose that it could
be an important consideration to put
into the problem
list in the clinical Case two the
visualization is the same you have each
participant in a Line and each Level of
detail in in a column sensitivity was
60.5 with  a Range to 40 to 100
57 if you consider interface One and 64
if you consider interface two and in
this clinical Case related to
pneumonia most of the
physicians documents the clinical
funding the pneumonia and the cse of the
disease in this Case
acute only
few  consider another attribute for
Problem that is the type of pneumonia
Community pneumonia
and
Only a few put information When They are
creating a Problem list about the
finding s and the laterality of the of
the
problem if you Take the new Case
clinical Case clinical Case a shoulder
Pain sensitivity was a 63c 5% with a 9% for
interface 1 and 6% for interface 2 Again
no statistical difference between the
two interfaces and if you Take account
of the details That physicians Select
All the physicians choose That the
clinical finding that is Pain  and the
finding Side that is shoulder is
important to put into
the problem
list some of them believe that the
laterality of the Pain was important and
Only a few consider that the cse
of the disease in this Case acute and
the type of Pain in this Case stavin
Where are important to the
problem in the
problem if you Take All the cases as a
whole you can find the sensitivity was
Almost 60 per with a Range for 47 to 80%
and 56 per  for interface 2 and 64 per
for
interface for interface two I'm sorry
and no statistical difference between
the two interface we find in
general you can see how this Part is the
consideration for each attribute in the
the problem When you're creating a
Problem lead for example for the course
it goes to 55
to
50% find inside is one of the best
attributes to add in the problem
list goes to Almost 80% to Almost
75 But You can see like other attributes
for example in this Case  the type of
Pain of the type of the neonia was Us
only in the 25% of the Times in
interface One and only in the 30% of the
Times in interface
2 also I take Note of all the comments
That doctors say to me when They  are
working with with the with this test And
I think they They are important comments
to share with you so I I dedicate a
slide for for this comments they Say
that the prob list is a is a guide the
list is not updated frequently therefore
information such  Evolution of the
disease become obsolete and it is not Okay
to put into the problem list too
much detail often create the duplication
of the problem list since the System is
not Mature Enough to recognize them as
the same Problem and showing the
problem another physician Say that  I
understand that the le of Problem is
useful for managing pram program for
chronic disease so he considered that
grouping the information would
facilitate the work of many and Because
of this they think that it is not correct
to put more detail in the problem list
and another physician  Say that the
problem list should serve to have a
quick idea of ​​the patient So You have to
put details in the clinical noes and not
in the in the problem
list in this consideration some topics
emerge for this
the First is the big problem ownership
even my  study was performed with
internal medicine and family physician
that in Our hospital are in ch of the
patient they Always talk about the
problem as the responsibility of others
so they say the is now updated but they
Never refer to themselves like we
don't maintain  the problem list we don't
put the the
correct Level of detail
policies that about the problem that
We have Our own policies in Our
hospital Are Not Are Not known For most
of the physician they They don't know
Who the policy says about  How
to work with the problem list and for
The People participating in my study the
utility of the problem is not Clear
another consideration is that
maintenance is challenge that at least
is considered by all The People participating
in they recognize that the update of the
problem  is a big challenge but They
don't do Nothing and taking account of
my specific working with granularity as
a Level of detail They don't have Clear
What Level of detail is needed and also
why more detail could
be
useful in this sense the  key Problem is
what Level of granularity is actually
required for the problem
list this will be dependent on on the use
that you declare for your Problem
list for your electronic Health record
Problem list and could be different if
you Focus your documentation process in
clinical care  in decision Support
development I also use this
for documentation and and billing
process and also has to do with Where
providers Will agree to spend extra time
to Reach to the best
granularity as possible and another
consideration is If doctors really
know What Level of detail they really
need and in this sense It's interesting
to know I work in the in the Health
information department and
Italian hospital so I work in All the process
from the creation of the the information
to the require of the information for
the physician and We have a Case that
some doctor ask Us For Please give me
All the right Hip fracture And I say I
can Give You right Hip fracture Because
you Never put the laterality in
the fracture so they Say that Maybe
laterality could be not useful to create
the problem that  When considering
doing some research they ask you for for
this kind of detail so Maybe they This
is what I I trying to say what they
Really Don't Know What Level or detail
they
need other consideration is that several
study show Advance In capture problems
To  complete the problem list but
there are no evidence in What Level of
detail are adequate if you take a
quickly review and the information you
can find a lot of clinical decision
Support System that with Data Mining or
other techniques look for information in
the free text  and create on offer the
creation of the problem but Never talk
about What is the Level of detail that
is the best consideration for the
creation in this Problem and the
hospitals must be Clear How they think
to address this Problem and the policies
about this must be  published and agree
with the with the
users about the policies When policies
exist They are deficient and One of the
example is my own hospital We have
Our own policies that say What
physicians should do When with the
problem list But You Had example of the
ownership  and the maintain
responsibilities That Are Not Clear even
When we say family physician are
responsible for the maintenance of the
Problem granularity As you can see as I
try to show you is a Complex issue
you can say that laterality is one of
the topics That  must be in All the
problem Because you have Problem Where
laterality has a different significance
that in other problems the same with
fund inside you can say fund inside is
mandatory when you are Talking About
Pain for example but Maybe It's not so
important if you are  talking about
pneumonia suppose that could be in the
lung then you
can make some difference in What part
of the lung is the pneumonia and also
It's difficult to standardize How To
measure This Level of detail So You can
say you can make some type of
experiments  studies like that and you
can play with Level of detail with the
sensitivity on some considerations but
If someone asks you What is the Level
of detail that you have in your System
say I don't know I I have
no good way to say to  you What is the
Level of detail of my of my System
Because I lose the chance to have the go
standard that is the physician with the
patient in the same
moment also user experience are available
there are some physicians that use the
problem a lot  and there are other
doctors that Never use the problem
list and in the Group that use the
problem list you have fanatic doctors
that document with the Extreme Level of
detail each consideration of the patient
and you have done ones that
correctly use the problem list  and put only
general
problems so This is other consideration
to take account in this sense interface
could be not be the Solution When I
started with this work Because of that
the name of the work improving
granularity in the problem l we as
Department Of he informatic are  quite
sure that If We put all Our Energy in
develop New interface Maybe the
Level of detail of Our Problem could
improve Now with this study We have a
Trend to find that Maybe the interface
has not such Impact in the Level
of detail  that We are looking for and
you Always must Take account that is
only one and Maybe Little Thing in the
Quality of documentation Problem in in
Health institutions So You must s
globally You Can't Focus on the problem
list if you have doctors that Never
write  anything in the in your System
but so when you are thinking
considerations to address these problems
you also must think in How this Will
be included in a more general Problem to
improve
granularity B the limitation in in my
studies even find 20 doctors that
give you  for free Almost one hour was
difficult this study was performed only
with 20 doctors so It's a small
numbers to have a general idea but we
can find some trends considering these
these users the setting Was perform the
study was performed hospital Italian so
hospital Italian is  a particular
institution in Argentina totally
different and what happens with the other
institution in Argentina and Our
hospital receives most of their
doctors from the School of medicine
so
we educate Our own doctors So The The
Only need the the only document model
that they know is  the problem oriented
electronic Health record and when you
receive a physician from another
institution that Used To document In A
traditional chronological
way you can find that Maybe the the
results could be
worse the problem list is not Used in
the same way in All the Place in  Our
institution the problem list is the axis
of Our System So You have all Our
process related to the problem list But
You can find other institution here like
use the problem list only to agree with
the meaningful use process so It's not
important to have more  detail on more
consideration about the problem and as I
Tell you before is really difficult How
find a standard to measure the Level of
detail of each
Problem What is the good things for this
study for Us at Italian hospital the
problem l is the axis of  Our he
information System So The Quality of the
problem list is really important for
Us the policies in Our hospital
says that the problem must have the
maximum granularity as possible in this
context We know Now that
doctors do not know Our policies many
Doctors have not  Clear which is usefulness
of the problem list We have One that
even can't find which is useful to
document but then We are looking for
them to have an idea which is important
to the problem list There is a large
scatter in term of the way  that Problem
is Used even in Our hospital and the
development of New interface that Where
we put all Our Energy might not be
Enough To solve This Problem so more
studies involving users could be
beneficial for Us to address these
problems in the conclusion the key
Problem is  what Level of granularity is
actually needed and this will be
dependent on the policies in the rules That
you Define for your institution There is
a wide dispersion in the way that each
heals Problem is detail It's not the same
for a Problem So You can find  a regular
standardized model to say How to
aggregate detail to each Problem and
This study is an approximation of some
trends in this considerations but
educations policies and information
Technology should address this topic in
order to find equilibrium between What
hospital institution needs and What users
are agree to
do so I want to say really Thanks to my
committee that Support Me And Give Me
all their help to Finish my My
project here all The People here in the
my department my Partner my The fellows
Who works with me that make me  the the
staying here really good and all the
people in the administrative process
here in the That Make Me feel like at
home my people at the Italian hospital
Buenos Aires that Believe in Me And sent
me two years Almost two years here and
did my work  for Me In in Buenos Aires
I really Thanks them to Support Me
and my wife my Crazy wife Who Leave
everything in Buenos Aires and follow me
in this Crazy Adventure so Thank
you Thank you very much
so Let me remind everyone that Because
this is a thesis  defense we'll have
public questions and then um um we'll
leave you to your committee
um the um as I'm listening to um the
discussion you know It's your study was
good and it raises a lot of Uh it
gets you thinking  a lot about Problem l
One of the one of the Classic rules of
certainly Of um You know for computer
users is um um you know If If people see
no value For what they're doing um then
um they probably won't Do it um  And I
Know you know we talk a lot about the
problem list in medicine but in reality
um at least from What I've seen very few
um health organizations actually use
What's in the problem list other than to
Look at it and so you know  Maybe Part Of
The Reason Why um doctors and other
clinicians Are Not willing to put Time
into It is Because
um they Just Don't see the problem l
Being Used For anything um whereas um
you know If there's other um
Uh there's other situations Where they
know If they enter some Data that
You Know It May accumulate and and
that can use it um do you at your
hospital or or really are you anywhere
Else of people who really do a lot with
the problem list or is it really mostly
um  Just something that we Look at
yeah for Us is a particular
consideration Because we use the prob
for all All the process in Our hospital
and depends on the value of the prob list
We have a specific example that is
traumatology they used to be the worst in
mation process but When they find the
chance to know that When we Ask for
information for research process If they
document for example The laterality Only
the laterality of the process of the Hip
of the femor fracture they obtain better
quality processing and facilitate
the reserve  process they became the
best creators of Problem in Our System
so I agree with you When if you Show
The value of having a real complete
Problem list Maybe it could be Easy to
convince the People to work in
the in this consideration  in another
situation We have people who have
Problem list only as a requirement of
some program and only use the problem is
to agree with this program and don't
use for any other Thing That agree with
the
PR
yes
First of all I think It's  a really
interesting topic Charli
fascinating real brief comment and that
is Where I work we do Team based care
and We have to use the problem list I
don't have time to read All the
notes the problem Is My First Thing Uh
but I've  got a
question How much do you think the
consistency between your two interfaces
was result of a recall bias in I did
Something I filled it out And I remember
what I filled out before and some
exactly the same Thing the next time I
do it and How  much is it that the
interests are so
common really I'm not sure I'm not sure
depend depend On A specific
consideration this was a study in a
protec Time but If Maybe if you are
working with physician in real Time
depend on How much  patient They are They
are waiting for them and Maybe
they have the chance to put but they
have a lot of patient Waiting so they
document in Another way is they have All
the time to document so Maybe
consistency could be not good  if you
if
you move this study to the real to the
real World for your study did you
reverse the order sometimes sometimes
interface One interface two and Ah Yes Ok
Yes so that so I'm sorry I can
understand the process is Case One
interface One  Case two interface One
Case interf One and then rotate the
consideration so is one
one
yeah so the results must have been a Little
disappointing For You Because you put a
big effort into trying to improve the
interface right Is there Any hope that
the interface can be improved  First of
all What Would you do next um and Second
the subjects must have said
some things about the difference between
the interfaces even though statistically
it didn't look like there was a
difference what they Tell you yeah I
think disappointed in in My First
objective  but It's a good result but now
We have We know where to put the Our
Energy so we think only changing the
interface we can change the
physician consideration in the sense
Now We are working to work with
decisions trying to explain which is
important and to We are working in all
Our hospital specific in these points
to create a friendly policies
visualizations that give the
physician the idea and What hospital are
expecting of When When working with
interface so we change the the Focus put
on the interface to  working with the
with the physician and here more then
What are they needed
and in the Second
consideration One of the things that the
new interface
was I received good comments about the the
Second interface is the way that they
can see We have a lot of chinese  so they
can see What the National association
says When They are creating this problem
so if you have the National association
classifications the definition and you
can also quickly add other details Like
You have in the in the right menu of the
problem they can create a more  accurate
Problem and this facilitate All the
research process Because some of the
Times they have some information in the
database That they
must modify to agree to the National
classification process so they find they
value with the good comments the
definition with the the organization for
the National associations  that is in the
one of the I can show you
quickly we put all Our Energy in this
Field but doctors really like only
this Because these are the the National
classification and they could Choose and
Feel good that They are document in a In
A
Way
yeah um the granularity of icd 10 has
been kind of turned into a joke really I
know You're not using snowed ct But You
did mention it are there nomenclatures
that lend themselves better toless than
others in your opinion
Yes If going to the maximum  granularity
I is not the one option so sn City is
the one of notion in this sense this New
interface we control all Our Problem
with Snow City so we don't Give sn City
directly to physicians physician write
the the problem that they want and in  a
backend System goes through Snow City If
the System finds a match that is mapping
offer this term in spanish in
argentinian spanish in hospital italian
spanish that is the prefer for the
hospital and c this ter with the Snow
City but If the ter is not a  mapping is
not exactly match with the Snow City
even So The physician can choose this
term and in the backend a te of coders
create with post coordinated in this
sense the generation of mapping and post
coordinator poord process Give Us the
chance To create This options so  Every
Time that we receive a term In The Last
10 years of c process We know Which
attribute could Go which is Problem in
Our Problem so We know that for example
for pneumonia could be good attribute
for this Problem Because other
doctors sometimes use this kind of
detail in Our
System
um char I have One of the quotes That
you put up um said something from a
doctor that Problem list should be broad
and If I want the details I go to the
clinical notes And I want to get to this
issue of sort  of Problem l versus the
clinical Note um the longer I've Used
ehrs the longer I think that clinical
notes are kind of a relic of paper um
you know Because encounters are in
individual Days And they Come on sheets
of paper and you know I'  ve been thinking
more and more that Uh I've been thinking
more of my patients as Problem lists in
other words a continuously evolving list
of problems That I change based on
that seems like it lends itself well to
What you're really doing here  um but
When I see a quote like that It makes me
feel like Doctors Are Not thinking in
Those terms and they're thinking in
terms of the way that we've Always done
things um and I'm a little bit confused
like where is  hospital Because you
mentioned things like um that Everything
is done in the problem list Uh and Can
you clarify exactly What's happening in
the problem list and are you really
implementing a Problem l oriented
Medical record or are you sort of doing
the same Thing That we'  ve Always done
but Just with more details in the
problem list and everything also in the
clinical notes and so no We have a real
Problem identity electronic Health
record so Every Time that you decide to
document something in the Our
electronic Health record you must choose
What is the watch Is The
Or What are the problems That you relate
with this action even if you are writing
a Note even if you
are prescribing drugs prescribing some
complementary study you must choose What
is the problem Health that It was
related To This action All  the actions
in in Our System are related to a
Problem
that doesn't mean that the Quality of
the document and the problem that It was
associated is the best but each of the
doctors must choose one problem to
each action that they want  to take
one Minor so If It's not Being
documented in the problem list that the
patient Had right osteomyelitis
refractory to Whatever antibiotics is it
Being document is it Being documented
nowhere in the Chart then no if you The
Reason is that We are looking for more
detail  is that physician could put
only as much as a Problem and then put
All the other information in the
clinical node and we Lost this
information Because We have Now actually
process to Mining in
inex Thank
you
ok